deutsche wirtschaft österreichische
wirtschaft niederländische wirtschaft
kommt nur aus der krone krise heraus wie
in europa aus der krise herauskommt wenn
man die wertschöpfungsketten die
lieferketten sieht und das weiß
eigentlich jeder
trotz aller taktischen spiele die
niederländer oder die österreicher
spielen und aus diesem grunde heraus ist
glaube ich der zwang am ende des tages
zu einer einigung zu kommen
jeweils im eigenen nationalen interesse
zu einer einigung zu kommen von großer
bedeutung wir müssen sehen dass junge
leute vor antrag dass etwas voran
getrieben werden und das machen micron
merkel dass dieses geld in
zukunftsprojekte gehen muss ist richtig
das ist aber auch dieser plan das sind
die vorschläge der kommission
das ist innovation forschung auch die
gesundheitssysteme krisenfest machen und
manches andere mehr nur dafür muss es
darf es geht es kann nicht einfach geld
in die kassen nationaler haushalte gehen
wie würde das bei uns einfach schlimm
bundesländer finanzausgleichs bahn
das ist in europa noch nie gegeben und
die kontrolle wird ausgeübt da geht
natürlich auch mal was schief in europa
das wir dann sieht man aber beim
bundesrechnungshof dass man auch in
deutschland schief geht ja aber es geht
ja dann nicht ob geld irgendwie
vielleicht am ende ein bisschen
versickert sondern es geht vor allen
dingen auch darum ob werte verkauft
werden und ob man darauf aufpasst was
vor allen dingen moment in
osteuropäischen staaten an
rechtsstaatlichkeit abgebaut wird und da
möchte man kontrolle haben ist das
verkehrt also jetzt erstmal geht es
darum wie das entschieden wird erstmalig
sind das 1 8 milliarden euro auf sieben
jahre das muss man sagen das ist
wesentlich weniger pro jahr als der
bundeshaushalt für ganz europa und eine
größenordnung deutlich zu machen
der europäische eigentlich europäische
haushalt ist ein drittel vom bundeshaus
sollte etwas mehr als ein drittel vom
bundeshaushalt und ich glaube deswegen
sind die größenordnung auch schon anders
zweiten sind wir in einer krise drin wo
schnell gehandelt werden muss der mit
wer aus der wirtschaftskrise
herauskommen und die lombardei instand
gesetzt worden ist mit lieferketten
können müssen wir sehen dass deutsche
wirtschaft nicht vorankommt ich komme
aus ostwestfalen lippe das sind
unternehmen die haben 50 70 prozent
ihres umsatzes im export im wesentlichen
europäischen union
deswegen muss man den gesamt laden
laufen lassen und nicht solche
diskussion zu führen
und wenn man die rechtsstaatlichkeit
damit verbindet dann ist die frage dass
wir an
einstimmigkeit brauchen das ist der
grösste viele in europa die
einstimmigkeit dass jeder jeden
erpressen kann und ich weiß nicht ob es
gelingt die rechtsstaatlichkeit mit
herrn orban zu vereinbaren und sondern
das gesamte konzept zu erholung europas
daran abhängig machen dass herr orban
eine möglichkeit dazu zu stimmen und
dann letzter punkt der mutter möchte
gerne dass er bei jeder einzelfrage
protest erheben könne ein veto hat wenn
die kommission einem land aus dem
programm etwas zur verfügung stellt und
zwar und begrenzt ein veto hat das hat
aber auch herr orban und der herr
jaschinski in polen und damit ist die
veranstaltung auch beenden